Oh my god!
Hello, hello everyone!
I'm so tired already!
Oh my god.
I just had to... you know like those moments when your mom comes into your room and then talks to you for like 30 minutes?
And I'm just like, I have a stream.
Please, please mom, I have a stream!
Please!
She came in and she's like, okay we need to talk about business.
I was like, I have a stream mom, please!
No, I don't want to be zoned out before the stream!
I need to hike myself up!
Oh my god, sorry.
That's why I'm like, I'm already like mentally exhausted at the moment.
Yeah.
I'm like, I'm already like mentally exhausted and zoned out.
And I'm like...
And then she left like two minutes before I had to start my stream.
So I was just like, okay, can you be awake now?
Oh no, I want a nap.
I want a nap!
I'm just like, no, no Doki!
You have to be awake!
You have to stream in two minutes!
But now I'm sleeping!
I'm sleepy!
I'm eepy now!
I was like, no mom!
Why didn't you come in the room after my stream?
Now I'm eepy!
Now I'm eepy because of all the business talk!
Not the eepy...
Anyways, so I got some coffee in here at the moment.
Cause I need to wake up.
I've been like...
There's been like so much work going on.
Like, I don't know.
I think I've like conditioned myself so that every time I like have to...
I have like fucking work talk going in.
Like, I'm just like, I wanna sleep.
It doesn't matter if like I just woke up or anything.
If I just woke up and I was like, alright, I'm feeling it.
And then they're like, alright, it's time for business talk.
And then I'll be like, I wanna sleep.
I wanna sleep now.
I just, I conditioned myself.
No, this is not good!
It's not good that I conditioned myself to be eepy!
Every time it's like, important business talk, important meeting time.
And then I'm like, important sleep time.
There's only one way to avoid business talk.
It's sleeping.
Gotta lift.
I got conditioned eepiness now, guys.
Anyway, another news!
Another news!
There's so many news!
There's so many news coming in!
But yeah, I was like, I was not eepy, but now I'm mega eepy.
But it's okay.
Streaming always makes me feel less eepy.
The longer I go.
And the more I stream, the longer I stream, the more, the less eepy I get.
Anyway, anyway, anyway, lots of exciting, lots of exciting news coming in.
So, I didn't realize this until I ended stream last night.
Also, like, I went to bed really fucking late last night.
Cause like, Hiro and I ended up talking for like, I think like, 3 plus hours straight after we ended stream.
So I think I went to bed around like, 3.5 hours.
So I think I went to bed around like, 5 to 6 AM.
Cause we just kept yapping afterwards.
She's a great friend.
Cause like, we were just like, hanging out and just talking about random stuff too.
And, but anyway, I found out after I ended stream, and after I finished yapping with Hiro.
That, it was announced that I will be at AVCon!
AvCon?
I don't know.
AVCon in Australia Adelaide!
So yes, another world tour, world tour spot, Dokie's world tour spot has been announced.
Another convention that I will be showing up is AVCon at Adelaide, Australia!
So I will be down under.
Um, and, uh, in AvCon for Australian goons, there will be meet and greets.
So, yes!
There will be meet and greets as well as, I think like, um, I don't know if I can announce it.
Cause it's not, it's not on the website itself.
I should have asked to be like, hey what can I say and what can I not say?
In terms of like, what will I be doing at AVCon?
Cause I don't think, uh, I don't think they wrote down yet.
They've announced what I will be doing at the convention.
I know what I'll be doing at the convention!
So, um...
Uh, so, I actually don't know yet.
I should, I should, I should ask first.
But, uh, the one thing I can say is the meet and greets.
Because like, I feel like, you know, even if I shouldn't have, if I wasn't supposed to spoil it.
It's not like, it's, uh, I mean I did quote retweet it.
So if they're like, oh my god you shouldn't have said it.
Well, I did quote retweet it and they know I quote retweet it.
And they didn't reprimand me for quote retweeting it.
So, and, and saying that it's a meet and greet.
So I think I'll be fine.
It's on the website though, wait is it?
Okay, wait let me double check.
Get involved, okay let's see.
Guest, let me see on the website.
Does it say what I'll be doing?
No, it doesn't say what I'll be doing.
It just says like, it just says like, this is my bio.
What do you guys mean?
The website doesn't even say what I'll be doing.
It just says like, my biography.
That I co-wrote.
You like it?
I co-wrote that.
Guys, you guys almost baited me into saying what I'll be doing there.
You guys, you guys almost, almost baited me there.
But yes, you guys like this?
I wrote this.
Okay, to be fair, I, to be fair, the organizer wrote it and then I edited it.
So technically I wrote this smile.
At first, they included like, at first it was like, oh my gosh, let me, let me not show you guys.
Let me like read off the original draft.
Cause I was, I had to edit it cause I was like, oh no.
And they were like, it's known for playing first person shooters, drawing sessions, musical performances, and just chatting sessions.
And I was like, okay, first off.
Let's, let's get rid of the musical performances.
Let's get rid of the musical performances.
Musical performances.
I was like, I was like, okay, I'm going to get rid of the musical performance part.
And then we changed it to like her tournament performances around the world.
So I like, I edited it a little bit and rewrote some stuff.
But yes, if you are going to Adelaide, Australia, if you're planning on going to Australia, you're planning on going to Adelaide.
I will be at AVCon.
And maybe you'll be lucky to get a meet and greet.
And for those people on like, in the different countries around the world, do not worry.
There's more convention announcements coming.
That's going to be coming out soon.
The more date weeks that pass, the more announcements are going to...
The more weeks that pass that's getting closer to certain conventions, the closer it gets to certain convention announcements.
So you do not, don't have to worry.
Being like, Doki, it's so far away from insert country here.
Do not worry.
There's more conventions that's going to come out soon.
So don't worry.
Australia is not the last.
Look, the Doki World Tour is not two conventions, guys.
The Doki World Tour is not two conventions, guys.
The Doki World Tour is more than two.
It's not three as well, guys.
Like, it doesn't stop at three.
It's not really a world tour if the tour ends at two.
Technically, it could be a world tour.
Because it's on either side of the world.
So like, you know, one at NA and then the other on the other side of the world.
So technically, it could be a...
You could say it's a world tour.
Just because there's...
It is on, like...
It's on the upper hemisphere and the lower hemisphere and then left and right.
The world is only two countries.
Canada and Australia.
We don't know what's in the middle yet, guys.
We haven't discovered what's in the middle of those two countries.
Another announcement.
Another, another, another little announcement.
The...
The SageM Slam 2 team.
I almost forgot.
Sorry.
2 team has been announced.
And apparently, I'll be on...
I was actually really surprised that I got on the fucking content team.
I was very surprised that I got on this team.
I didn't think I was actually gonna get on this team.
But it's gonna be with Brawl Pro, Lazy Mat Man, Slime.
And Kony.
So that's gonna be my Tekken 8 team.
The Not A King main team.
Exactly.
I can't believe they put me on a team with all these disgusting King players.
Oh my god.
Like, what am I gonna do with this information?
How is he gonna coach me?
On my actual main player play?
I'm gonna be playing as the playable character, Eddie.
I can't fucking believe it.
They want me to fail.
She uploads a dead Kirito on Twitter.
Look.
I just did it to see if I could.
Okay, guys?
I...
I guess.
I actually...
It was really nice.
Because I was asking about like...
Oh, hey guys.
Like...
Oh, do you guys know...
Do you have any recommendations on like actual...
Like...
Like what controller they use for fighting games?
And...
Oh my gosh.
What were they?
It was so nice of them.
But the Junk Food Custom Arcades actually like reached out.
They reached out in DMs saying they wanted to send me a free controller.
Like one of their like mini-packs.
I think that's the Loverless mini-box for free.
I asked.
I was like, oh, that's so cool.
Can...
Would you think it would like arrive in time?
Like arrive in time before they can get some prizes?
Yeah, yeah, they will.
So like they're sending me...
I love free stuff.
You know why?
Because like that means money doesn't leave my bank account.
And I still get the item.
Okay.
A snack box micro.
Isn't that great?
Oh my gosh.
Who doesn't love free stuff?
Yeah.
Free is good.
Who doesn't love free stuff?
So yeah, they're sending me a free snack box.
I think that's what it's called.
A snack box micro.
And so I'm looking forward to trying it out.
But yeah.
Yeah, I feel like people are like, oh my gosh, she did the RDC, but it's not even that difficult to do.
Like, why?
Like, no, I'm actually serious.
Like, I don't think it was, it wasn't that difficult to like, get those buttons, like, done.
I just like, watched one video and because everyone was, I was like, alright.
I was just like, okay, what are the king combos of a character I wasn't gonna play?
Yeah, it's not difficult.
And then people were like, wow!
The issue is, can I do it at an actual match though?
I'm just a natural grappler.
What can I say?
The Doki Grav.
The real talent is if I could do it in a real game.
In a real, with a real actual person.
But like, it literally just took me like, five minutes.
Cause like, they're like, okay, you press those buttons.
And I was like, okay, I press those buttons.
And I was like, oh, there it is!
I'm, whoa!
There it is!
It's actually a fun combo though.
It's, I feel like that's like, the first combo, like, I actually sort of paid attention to.
Do you ever, I do!
I actually do!
I actually do remember!
It's right, down, slanted, right, and then, uh...
What were my controller buttons?
Y, X.
And then after Y, X, you press, uh...
You press right, down, slanted, uh...
Uh, fuck.
Okay, give me a sec.
No, no, no!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Why?
No, it's...
It's right, down, slanted...
Right, R3.
Then, right, down, slanted...
Uh, Y, X.
And then, B, B, Y.
Bam!
What is slanted?
I almost forgot.
Look, slanted is...
What?
It is slanted!
It is technically slanted!
I am right, it's just that I have my own words.
Look, all I'm saying is that before it was called diagonal, it had no...
People created, invented their own names, okay?
Look, look, let me tell you guys.
The difference between a pioneer and a sheep.
A sheep?
Well...
A sheep will follow what other people would say.
A pioneer will invent their own terms.
She's not wrong, though.
I am not a sheep.
I am a pioneer.
I... I fucking invent my own combos.
My own terminology.
So, I'm super excited...
Uh...
To play with my team.
I can't believe I replaced a super.
I thought that was really funny.
Because, like, my teammates were all like, Oh my god!
I can't believe it!
The boys are back!
And even better!
Because I replaced...
I'm like...
The fucking replacement for super.
And they're just like, oh my god, this is the dream team.
You had fun doing combo?
Congrats, Doki.
You're better than 90% of the FGC.
But then, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I think the death cradle is so fun.
Because if I hit it, I don't have to do anything for like 80% of the game.
Like...
It's the best, because like...
Because like, then I can just spend majority of time just chilling in the cutscene.
And I think that's why I was really into King.
Because I realized, if I hit these grapples, if I hit these like throws, I get to do like 50% less than the rest of the player base.
And...
It's a good... I get downtime.
Exactly.
Like, in that fucking...
If I hit the RDC, I'll have...
Because like, what kind of newbie is going to learn how to break the RDC anyway?
Like, I don't know how the fuck to break the RDC.
But anyway...
It's a good investment learning all the...
Learning all the grapples and the throws now.
So like, if I get anybody in the RDC, I can literally leave my controller.
And just go to the bathroom and then come back.
And they're still fucking gripped.
And then I...
And then I put them into another RDC.
And then I leave my PC, get water, and then KO.
Like, it's so easy.
It's like resetting after losing a fight in Overwatch.
Who's gonna learn how to break RDCs?
He's a girl on a team of only King mates.
That's... That's why...
This is why I...
This is why I picked King guys.
Not to plan to P-Break.
This is why I wanted to play King as my secondary character.
Because King is merely just a backup.
A backup for my actual main character.
Which I will leave as a secret for now.
He's only...
He's only the backup, guys.
Anyway...
I am...
Super hyped to try out Hades Tour!
The early access!
Uh...
So yeah, they just dropped this out of nowhere.
And was just like, Hey guys!
Uh...
You thought this was Silksong?
Joke's on you guys.
We actually completed a game.
Here's Hades Silksong.
I'm sorry.
That's like...
Silksong does not deserve that random stray hit.
Um...
Anyway...
They basically dropped Hades 2...
Out of...
Out of nowhere.
And...
Um...
I'm super excited!
Because I very much enjoyed Hades 1!
So I'm very excited to try out...
Hades...
That hurts!
Jokey!
I'm very...
Um...
Very excited...
To try out Hades 2.
Just like every other streamer out there.
Uh...
Because the FOMO was hitting it real hard.
The fear of missing out was real hard.
You guys might...
I might be like the 876th streamer you've watched playing.
So...
I'm going to be playing Hades 2.
Um...
And...
Uh...
And now I'm going to be at 877th streamer to watch me play...
Watch play Hades 2.
Yay!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
There we go.
I heard it was really good.
I heard that like...
Uh...
I heard like majority of the game was practically finished.
In terms of like...
The meat of it.
And like...
The only thing they haven't...
Really added yet...
Was the ending.
And like some of the visual assets.
Like some of the like visuals and stuff that hasn't...
Uh...
And so...
Yeah, there's apparently a lot of content.
It's not finished yet.
It's merely early access.
But people are telling me that the ending...
The ending isn't...
Uh...
Done yet.
And it's missing a lot of like just visual assets.
But like the main game itself.
Like there's a lot of story...
And stuff.
A lot of like audio and stuff is done...
Uh...
Already.
So yeah.
It's gonna be interesting.
It's gonna be interesting to see.
What's up?
Alright.
Is sound guy on?
Sound guy!
He's on!
I see you sound guy.
Alright.
Let's go.
Or use mouse and keyboard.
Welcome to Hades 2.
This game is in early access.
Which means we're actively working on it based on our plans.
Yeah.
See?
Early access.
Good luck killing time.
Whoa.
Whoa!
It's so loud.
Let me...
Bummmmm.
Meep!
Thank you for the 20 gift and chips!
Thank you!
How's the new PC dokey?
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
It's like...
Sitting there.
Like...
You know?
It's...
This PC feels like he's doing okay.
There.
It's existing.
It's...
Like...
All right.
Let's see.
Maybe turn down the music.
Oh no!
Sound guy!
What do you think, sound guy?
What do you think?
Display.
V-sync.
Am I full screen or what am I?
50% brightness.
Interface.
Button labels.
Disable screen saver.
Control.
Address.
Attack.
Dash.
Q.
Special.
Hex.
What was hex?
Uh...
What else is there?
Rarity.
Statue.
Book of Shadows.
Forget-me-not.
Boon info.
Okay.
I feel like...
Cast.
I want to...
Mouse and keyboard.
So...
Yeah.
Mouse and keyboard.
Oh!
It's hex super move.
Okay.
Hex is super move.
So, hex...
F.
Oh!
Alright.
I think for now...
God mode.
This is what makes you tougher.
More so whenever you fail.
Failure is the greatest...
Oh!
Aim assist.
I love...
Wait.
Actually, no.
We don't need aim assist.
Did I...
Guys, did I use aim assist last time?
Maybe I do need aim assist.
Did I use aim assist, guys?
Okay.
That's good.
Alright.
Let's start.
Empty save slot.
See?
Now you know I didn't play in advance to make myself look good.
Oh!
Yeah.
What happened to the first Hades?
Oh!
It's a Kronos.
Who's Kronos?
Kronos is like time, right?
Dong, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Your Cantonese is excellent.
I really appreciate that.
You're not like my high school friends that make fun of my Cantonese.
Trauma.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Whoa, Hades!
What happened?
Damn, Hades!
Alright.
I have this.
What's this?
Oh!
What the fuck did I use?
What is this?
Okay.
I have no idea what any of these buttons are.
E.
Kronos is the father of Hades?
Oh shit!
Okay.
Sorry.
It's been a while.
Okay.
There you go.
Sorry.
It's been a while.
Forgot what dodging is like.
I'm already going full king at the moment.
Where it's all full offensive.
No defense.
My favorite.
No one needs to do defense.
Wait.
Does this like go all the way?
Oh, it does!
Wait.
Nice.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm learning, guys.
Yay!
Boop, boop, boop.
Goodbye.
I have no idea what's going on in this story.
But that's okay.
Okay.
What does this do?
Do I just like snare them?
Oh, I snare them!
Okay.
Alright.
I'm figuring it out.
I'm just gonna go.
Wow!
Nice.
That's fine.
We're okay.
And then snare.
Okay.
I don't know the range.
I don't...
Wait.
Who's he?
Who's this guy?
Apollo!
Have I seen him before?
I don't remember anything except for Aphrodite and Poseidon.
And then the Snow Grandma who I hated the power-ups from.
Nova Strike.
Uh...
Hot.
Look.
The thing is they're all...
They're gods and goddesses.
They're supposed...
They're meant to be like the hottest thing that's out there because they're gods and goddesses.
Yeah.
They're all supposed to be hot.
Oh, Apollo is new.
Okay.
Let's see.
Your attacks deal more damage.
Your sprint is faster and inflicts daze.
When standing in your cast, gradually restore...
What is the magic required for powerful...
Wait.
What should I get, guys?
Blinding sprint.
Nova Strike.
You guys can't be like, Doki, the game came out.
We don't know what's good yet.
You can't say that because Hades 2 has already been grinded and analyzed and like inspected for fucking hours now.
Like for like days.
Everybody knows what's meta.
It's already been inspected and analyzed and theorized.
Let's do the audio.
Let's see.
You put music at 80, sound effects at 90.
Okay.
I'll put the music at 70 then.
And then we bring up the overall game.
And... oh.
All right.
Okay.
Maybe I'll turn this down too.
But that's ambience.
Whoops.
All right.
Let's just put...
And then we'll adjust the game volume.
Yeah.
All right.
Here we go.
No roller?
We don't need roller.
We got practice M and K for the tournament too.
Because I'm using leverless.
There we go.
Snared.
I don't like this weapon at all.
Not gonna lie.
I'm not gonna lie.
I missed the...
I missed the gun and the bow.
I think gun and bow was the best.
Not huge fan.
Oh shit.
Where are these guys?
What is this story?
Am I not gonna find out the story until I die?
Just like in Hades one?
I think that was how it happened in Hades one.
I didn't find out the story until I died.
Wait.
What's that?
What did I get?
Mostly used with inculcating.
Incantation involving dispelling and nullification.
Okay.
What the fuck is that?
Where are these items?
What?
What did I...
Mostly used for unlocking arcana cards.
Common reward for clearing encounters.
Okay.
That's interesting.
I have no idea what they are.
What is this?
What's more important?
I don't know.
Okay.
You can't say one because I haven't even given them any numbers yet.
That one?
Like...
Do we go with left or right?
Neither.
Wait.
What are ashes again?
Is that an ash?
Oh.
Okay.
Ashes are important.
Alright.
Spindles.
What are spindles?
Oh.
That's what's...
Oh!
Because they spin!
Oh my god!
It's like they named these monsters after kindergartners!
Okay.
This is it.
I love it.
Like...
I don't know if you guys have ever seen...
There was like a YouTube series where it was like they let...
They try to let kids...
Oh shit!
No!
Excuse me spindles.
I am trying to have a nice yapping session with my dragoons.
Like they're like...
Let a child...
Let a child come up with like a tea.
And they're like...
It's supposed to be the most dumb TV show idea.
And it is the most nonsensical thing ever.
Alright.
Simplicity has its best...
Oh!
Wait!
That's a...
Is that bone?
I don't remember.
Oh my gosh!
I actually don't remember it.
It's crazy.
I played this game for so long.
But I actually don't remember majority of this...
The visuals.
Oh!
That's right.
Do I have an ult yet?
Nope.
Oh!
No!
Guys!
Guys, I got distracted!
Guys, it doesn't count!
I got distracted!
No!
It doesn't count!
I looked at chat!
Guys, I looked at chat!
Oh my god, I can put the frogs.
It was ping!
I swear it was the ping, guys!
I swear!
It was the ping!
That's me.
Am I the baby?
It doesn't count!
Don't make me restart my game right now and start a new save file.
You know what?
Alright, hey guys!
Hey everybody!
So like, I don't know if you heard about Hades 2.
But...
Oh my god!
I can't wait to start Hades 2 with all of you!
I'm so excited!
Oh my gosh, I can't believe they dropped this early access.
They dropped this early access out of nowhere!
I'm so... this is my first time experience.
Whoa!
Where am I?
Is this... wait, I'm a girl now?
Wait, I know Kronos.
Kronos is like the time god, right?
Restore?
Okay, actually that was new.
So natural!
Oh my god, whoa!
Lost souls?
Okay, and then...
What do I... wait, do I... can I not do that?
Oh wait, I can read!
Oh wait, I mean like...
Oh, I don't like that key binding.
Give me a sec guys.
Wow!
What the heck is that key binding?
Let me like fix that real quick.
Let me fix that key binding real fast.
My first time using this new key bind.
Okay, I'm a YouTube gamer.
What do you mean?
I'm just giving my first time reaction.
To Hades 2.
Never played this game in the...
This is the first five minutes playing it.
We just had a 40 minutes Zaxxed On chat.
Wait, who is he?
What's this?
Whose god is this?
First impression.
Wait, Apollo?
Has he... has he been in the...
In the Hades one?
Guys?
Whoa!
Hey guys!
Who is that?
Who can be hot guy?
They're all gods and goddesses.
Of course they're hot.
They're all supposed to be hot.
Because they're a god.
I need my aid.
Let's see if I need theirs.
Damn.
I swear I saw him before.
Yeah, from like the streamer you watched before me.
Because everybody's been playing Hades 2 now.
So of course you've seen him before.
Like, I don't know what you mean.
Okay, let's lock him up here.
All right, nice.
Okay, we put...
Wait.
All right, we adjust the volume a little bit too.
We put sound effects down another 10.
Okay, I'll put like 62.
And then we put...
Music down another 5.
Okay, that means 60.
That means 10.
And then...
And then we'll bring up the game a little bit more.
All right, let me know.
Okay.
There we go.
That should be good, right?
Oh, shit.
No mistakes.
Oh my god.
No hit run right here.
First time playing, I already got no hit run.
That's actually crazy.
I'm actually not going to die.
I'm actually talented at this game.
Wait, what's an ash?
All right.
Let's grab this real fast.
So close to greatness.
All right, sound guy.
Let me know if this sounds better.
This game is pretty easy for now.
I don't know.
I'm not really feeling this weapon though.
So far.
Oh, still no hit run.
Still a no hit run.
I don't know what your dad's talking about.
There we go.
Nice.
Oh, oh, wait.
No.
Oh, shit.
How could he touch me like that?
It's not no I'm a god.
This.
All right.
I just hit him from here.
I don't think they can hurt me.
Yeah.
Thanks for rewinding this stream.
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What do you mean rewind?
Oh, shit.
It's rewind time.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, it's a super chat.
I actually don't know this.
What's the left side?
No hit run dead.
Oh, shit.
It's rewind time.
Left?
Okay.
I have no idea what...
I actually have no idea what this is.
Is this a fire?
Is this a fire god?
Oh, my god.
Spindles.
My first time seeing them.
Whatever they are.
Wait, can I just spam this?
Wait, I can.
Wait, I don't even have to get close to them.
Oh, my god.
I just be like pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
Wait!
This is so broken.
The attacks are so slow, so I can literally just spam this.
Okay.
And then he gets close to me here.
Yeah, I can literally just spam this in there.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
Did not expect him to actually get close to me though.
That was like the one thing that was going to counter me.
Distance.
Yeah.
Yeah, I could literally just spam this forever.
It's so nice.
And then...
She stays as she dies.
What do you mean?
I made it so far for my first try.
Damn Doki, doing so good.
Not like the streamer I was just watching.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I wonder who that streamer could be.
Was it... was it BokiDurd?
Hahaha!
Yeah, BokiDurd is pretty fucking bad at video games.
Oh, Hestia?
Wait, is this another gilf?
Oh my god!
And she's Scottish too!
Hahaha!
See?
There's a granny for everybody!
It's like, would you want a Scottish granny?
Or the other one?
Uh, she's new.
Yeah, she's new!
Alright.
Your cast repeatedly inflicts scorch or restore, but you have minus 20%...
No, what the fuck?
Your special launches a fiery projectile, but uses 10 magic.
Controlled... or...
I feel like scorch would be better, right?
One?
Wouldn't one be better?
Yeah, but then I lose 20% of re... health.
A change to your life limit.
Yeah.
Wouldn't it be bad?
Because I lose my health limit and stuff.
I feel like I'm gonna go with one.
Fire damage.
Wait, another scorch!
But then there's a boss!
But then I can have money!
Wait, is this a shop?
This is a shop, right?
How much money do I have?
77?
Alright, left or right?
Money or... or granny?
Money or granny?
Oh, I lose a chopper.
Okay.
Doki bird is so much better than that last streamer, Choki.
Yeah.
That sounds like a gamer that fucking sucks.
Charon.
Oh hey, there he is!
Wait, I don't have money.
Wait, can we actually date him now?
If you date dev, you can never die.
Pro tip.
I'll just grab the plus one smoldering.
Because you guys fucked me over.
Oh, it's a placeholder?
He just wasn't hot enough.
Sorry, guys.
They were like, wow!
Okay, don't be that close to the ring guy.
I figured it out.
I learned.
I need to make sure...
Are you fucking kidding me?!
I got stuck here because I couldn't dash!
Oh!
Okay, that was bullshit.
I actually got hit by everything that was possible.
That was actually crazy.
Like, anything that could hit me, hit me there.
Oh my god.
Just don't get close.
Just stay back here.
Safe in your safe space.
There's no way they could catch me now.
I'm safe.
Look at that.
There's no way.
Range them.
This is it.
This is the key.
If I range them, they can never hit me.
Wait, they're ranging me.
Wait, that's illegal.
Wait a minute.
Why are you running away from me?!
This was my strat!
They're using my strat against me!
What the fuck is wrong with these freaks?!
I'm not gonna let you get away with this.
I'm the main character!
Okay.
It's fine.
If I spam this... If I spam right click, they'll never get me.
Nice.
They're better at your strat.
I don't know what the fuck you're talking about.
Wait, what's this?
What's the time?
There's a time and then there's heart.
I don't remember any of these.
Is that HP?
The god of cheese.
Right side, left or right?
Oh, is this coins?
Oh, they're coins!
They're time coins.
We'll get health.
They're like time coins.
I see.
Oh no.
Guys.
Guys, this is a bit bad.
Just a little bit.
Just a little bad.
Alright.
Just a little bit.
I just gotta keep running.
Okay, nice.
And then they'll just go in the fire.
And then I'll just be over here.
They can't get me if I like...
Oh, see?
They can't get me.
Oh my god.
I almost like fucking ran into that guy.
Because I assumed he was stunned.
Nice.
Easy.
I got my heart back.
See?
Nothing to worry about.
For my very first run.
You guys said ash is the best, right?
Ash is better than whatever the fuck this is.
What is that?
Psych?
To activate more mostly used...
Is ash the best one?
To farm?
That's our god of cheese.
Alright, we'll do more ash.
I love cheesing the game.
That's what I was built for.
This is why I'm totally not playing king.
Alright, I think I stay back here.
It'll be fine.
Okay, I hate the worms though.
The worms are actually really cringe.
Like, I can't believe they would like run away from me.
What kind of player are you?
Okay, I can stun these guys before they do anything, which is good.
And then I'll just burn these guys real fast.
And then...
Oh, I don't like that.
Whoa!
Stay away from me.
Stay away from me, screamer.
And then...
Get rid of him.
And it will get rid of you.
Easy!
They can't use my strat against me.
I copyrighted and trademarked it.
They gotta pay me first.
Wait, what's the purple?
Every time you use my strat, you gotta pay me a 5% commission fee.
What's the purple?
New.
Is it a good new or a bad new?
Another currency?
What?
Bones are a currency?
Alright, who wants to give me their bones?
Oh!
Whoa!
They locked me in!
I thought I could run around here.
That's bullshit.
Oh god.
Oh!
Oh, wait, I don't like this guy.
Wait.
Wait, this guy fucking sucks.
Alright, nice.
They actually rushed me.
Actually, really don't...
Oh, wait, he's stuck!
He's actually stuck!
Wait, use the trees against them!
Okay.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
Nice.
Oh, the terrain kill kills everybody!
Okay, I'm learning.
Bones.
What is the bones?
Common reward for clearing most used for trades for most valuable resources.
I guess I won't find out until I die.
It's gonna be hard because I don't die.
Alright, let's see.
The trees are actually so good for destroying stuff.
Your cast snares them, by the way.
Yeah, I noticed that.
Yeah, the banshees fucking suck.
I hate it.
Alright.
Does it sound better now, Sound Guy?
Okay.
Okay, and then I'll just use this and spam.
Wait, never mind.
I actually like this weapon.
This weapon is pretty cool.
I'll never have to get close to them again.
I stopped looking at my screen!
Okay.
So, I actually stopped looking at my screen because I kept spamming.
It's a very nice cheese weapon.
Oh, shit.
Oh, no.
Oh, thank God I snared them though.
Guys, I don't think they like it!
It's okay.
I can do it again.
Yay!
Just line up for me, guys.
Line up for me.
Oh, it's the other Snow Granny!
Oh, it's because it's ice and fire!
Ice and fire!
Please!
I'll not lose her again!
Wait, is her mom dead?
Oh, my God!
So, it's like, do you want a British Granny or a Scottish Granny?
The Grandmother!
Grannies of all flavours!
That's your Granny!
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Grandmother!
Your special deals more damage.
And if like freeze...
Your sprint forms cycle... wait I can sprint?
Hold to run at top speed.
Your attack deals more damage but uses... wait...
Weed killer deals more damage...
Can I do freeze and fire?
Wait, is it possible to do freeze and fire at the same time?
Oh but then that's a rare.
Wait you're right.
Is weed killer... good?
Uh, we'll try it I guess.
Two is the best sprint.
They're all good!
You just had the worst fucking power ups granny!
What happened?
What happened to meter?
One,
okay.
Ice and fire.
Three is an early win!
Why did you not say that?
Why did you not say three is an early win early game?
I would have picked that!
No!
Okay I gain max magic.
Okay nice.
You can never charge attacks though.
Oh shit wait what?
What the fuck was that?
Wait I could do that?
Oh my god guys!
Did you guys know you can charge?
Guys did you know you can charge attacks?
Guys I discovered a new tech!
Everybody!
Live right here on stream the first person to use this new tech.
No way!
Hey hey hey hey hey!
Hey hey hey hey!
Turkey please!
Hecate!
Oh she's my teacher look at her abs!
For all your guidance and the compliment.
In my place you'd have done the same.
However now is not the time for pleasantries.
I'm pretty sure some of my goons here wanted to get stepped on by her.
My capability.
My capabilities?
We don't have to face each other here.
Even though my task has already begun.
Your training shall never be complete.
And I would...
Oh whoops sorry I feel like she finished talking.
What's going on?
Woah!
What?
Why?
What the fuck?
I don't like this.
Oh I don't like this.
Oh what the fuck?
She's so difficult!
Oh I'm so scared.
I'm actually so scared.
Okay.
Oh!
She's so dumb!
Okay okay okay there's too many things going on in my screen.
There's too many things going on in my screen.
I don't like this.
I don't like it when I don't know what's going on.
Oh god.
That freezer?
I can't tell.
Oh!
No no no no no no no no no.
I can't touch!
Oh shit!
No!
Why did I take the epic?
Expert thank you for the super chat.
Thank you thank you.
Holy shit.
I don't know.
I think I made it pretty far for my first try.
I mean I got to the boss stage.
That was pretty good.
Yeah that was good for a first run.
Hello little frog.
Alright.
How's the sound by the way?
I remember I asked that earlier for sound guide but I forgot to read the chat.
This old unfinished painting.
Don't look away.
Don't forget all that the Titan took from you.
Alright so they took my family?
Wait so I'm like the sister of Hades?
That's why I'm Hades too!
Cause like his parents was like we can make a better child and then she's Hades too.
Wait what?
Oh there.
Who dares disturb my eternal rest?
You trifle with powers far beyond your comprehension witch.
Speak!
That was pretty decent right Mel?
Maybe pushing it.
Okay if I call you witch.
Oh she's gonna be the- Dora's gonna be the new Medusa head that everybody wants to fuck.
Which works for me in context.
And I saw you haunting more than all Dora.
But better than me.
It's the only thing I have to do.
I'm gonna be the new Medusa.
Okay here you go.
Then be gone.
I miss Medusa.
You guys have Dora now!
Stand tall and show me your weakness.
The crossroads.
Come here.
Hello.
Time forced our hand, Melanoi.
Nereus' soul expected you to slay our enemy last night on her new moon no less.
But...
I lack such forgiveness for my failure, had Mistress Hecate.
The Titan yet lives, and Olympus yet burns, while I'm back where I started.
What is it I accomplished?
Oh god sorry.
I meant like Zagreus.
I forgot the main character's name because his name was so...
like difficult to remember and not easy to the tongue.
So like I kept thinking of Hades as the main- as the little kid, the little punk.
But I still believe that Hades and his wife can be friends.
And my wife was like, we're gonna have another child who's better than you and that's why it's called Hades 2.
Zaggy.
Zaggy my boy.
We're really close friends.
That's why I call him Zaggy.
Death to Kronos?
Is he the one that killed his fa- her family?
Death to Kronos.
Sounds like a fucking cult.
What is this?
He's being purified?
Who are you?
Oh!
O-Odyssey!
Oh my god!
Is he gonna be the new- new Reaper guy that everybody wants to bang?
As well?
Already hit a wall.
Knocked your scrawny ass all the way back there.
Oh my god, she's gonna be the new ex-girlfriend!
It's insane that she's sending you out on foot all on your own.
Your skepticism's too much.
Mom?
There's a new ex-girlfriend that everybody wants to bang too!
Wait, salute.
Hail shades.
Our fight is just getting started.
Holy mo- Oh, you already ditch Hecate?
That's so fast.
You're not loyal.
Jackals!
You're not loyal!
You're already willing to ditch Hecate!
You're witch abs!
What are you, mom number one?
What about- No!
Hecate was mom number one!
Oh hey, she's still alive.
Hypnos.
No ditch?
No.
Addy!
Zess.
Oh yeah, you're right.
She's gonna be the new ex-girlfriend.
This is so much fun.
Oh wait, tree?
Wait, what?
Why is dog a statue?
Let me pet.
Guys, to be fair, it makes sense that you're adding, because this is like- You know, the Mythos back then, the Romans and the Greeks banged everything.
So it makes sense that you're adding the mythos again.
There were orgies everywhere.
We're just following the lore.
Cat, pet, shit game.
Exactly.
While you channel your moves, everything moves slower.
Ooh, I like that.
Oh, that's what the ash is for!
I see.
Do foes, after you exit a location, restore heart or twice that you have no more than 30% deal?
You know I want to deal 30%.
Me when I'm actually green.
Hold to run at top speed.
Gain.
Wait, I want to gain 20%.
Is regen actually good?
Wait, how much do I have?
I don't even know.
I don't know how much I have.
Listen, you're attacking special dealer.
Take the heal.
Restore every...
Ooh, restore magic every one second!
No!
Am I broke now?
Do I have six?
Guys, I think I'm broke now.
Man, I unlocked a lot of stuff.
That's nice.
Wait, can I punch this?
Have they unlocked more than one weapon yet?
Like in the early access?
Or like, is it only like one weapon so far?
Oh wait, no!
There is other weapons.
Where are you?
That's me.
Oh, is that the guy beat up?
It is!
Now he's like in war armor.
Okay, we can't unlock anything yet.
Can we?
We have the witch's staff.
Silver?
How do I unlock that?
How do I get silver?
It's him, the skeleton!
I want to be greeted on those abs like, Jeez, Deadpool, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Which is the best one so far for you guys?
What do you guys think is the best one?
Oh, he has a beard?
Okay.
Wait, what?
Okay, and then...
And then press or hold?
Oh my god!
I'm running!
Oh, when you hold, you can sprint!
Oh!
Wait, is there a cooldown to sprinting?
Let me check.
Wait, there's no cooldown when it comes to sprinting!
Hold.
And then...
Special, then hold to release.
Okay.
Watch and learn!
Alright.
I did it.
Oh, I just had to strike him.
And then...
Guys, I can't believe it.
I could have...
I could have, like, charged this up.
Yeah!
Wait, what if I kill him?
Alright.
Goodbye.
That just means I'm better.
Wait, is he dead forever?
No, he's still alive!
See, he's unkillable.
Killable!
That means I didn't commit war crimes.
Wait, what's this?
Do I just leave?
Wait,
did I just accidentally started the game?
Oh no, it was just lore.
Okay, I was gonna be like, oh that's awkward.
That's cool.
I was supposed to run a lot.
I feel like I'm gonna get lost.
Not lost, but like...
I feel like I'm gonna get more confused if I just keep running.
That sounds like something what I would do.
I just accidentally like run into the enemy.
Okay, is that everything?
Is there anything else?
I'm not sure.
That's everything, right?
Yeah.
Alright, that's time.
It's time to go out.
Wait.
But there's two doors.
Go up?
Or go out?
Go up.
Oh, nevermind.
Go down!
Oh, now I'm starting!
Okay.
Poseidon!
Hey, long lost niece!
You live!
Hello, Posidon!
We thought you were the same great as your father.
And your mother, and your brother.
How about we turn the tide.
And extract terrible revenge for poor, old Hades and his kin.
Okay, your attack hits foe with a splash that knocks other foes away.
You cast Immune Deadness dealing damage and knocking foes away.
After you strike foes with your weapon, a spirit bubble may be activated.
What the fuck is a spirit bubble?
There's an ill for everybody.
Oh my god, isn't that great?
I guess cast immediately explodes seems really nice.
Right?
Boom.
Oh, there you go.
Alright.
I need to remember not to like...
I need to remember not to like accidentally use up all my MP in the beginning.
Okay, nice.
Cleared.
Here I go.
One is great?
Well then.
That's great information to know.
I wish I figured that out sooner.
Alright, I'll just charge this.
Wait, spamming is just better.
For now.
Boop.
Fucking right, you can't touch me.
Yay!
Nice.
Easy.
Okay, and then... spam.
Oh!
Wow!
You touched me!
Oh shit, okay.
I'm sorry.
After I get touched... when I get hit once, I start panicking.
Yay!
Alright guys, wait.
Give me a sec.
Let me mute real quick.
I gotta check your voicemail.
Nevermind.
Like, I was getting like spam caught like three times in a row.
And then I was like, okay, there's a voicemail.
And then I looked up the voicemail and it was like a two second voicemail.
I was like, okay, I guess I'll never know.
I...
I was like, alright, I guess I'll never know.
I was like, alright...
Whatever.
Sorry, misclicked three times in a row, guys.
Sorry about that.
Do I need to cast this?
Is the casting like...
Strong enough?
Like, is it like...
To be worth it?
I don't know.
I can't tell yet.
I want my two seconds of stream back.
Yeah, I'm back.
Yeah, she did.
How could she not send word?
Because I'm a secret.
I'm a secret child.
Alright, your special deals more damage and inflict freeze.
Guys, I was hoping I would get like the rarity...
The rare special again.
I take interlocation prime, a barrier that absorbs one...
Wow, a whole one damage?
Great.
Wait, is this good?
Two.
I get to have like my...
Uh...
I get to regen my magic.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, wait, that's so fucking fast.
Holy shit.
Do I need bones?
Or do I need ash more?
I feel like I haven't used any bones yet.
Oh, one hit.
Oh...
One instance.
Sorry, English is my first language.
Uh...
Hahaha.
Okay, nice.
And we can just do this for now.
Yeah!
Oh shit.
Okay, that's not what I expected.
Woop woop woop woop woop!
That's also not what I expected.
So we'll snare them here.
And then...
Boop!
Exactly.
There.
Easiest fucking game of my life.
Ash time!
Taking the flowers!
Oh wait!
That upgrades my weapon!
Okay.
Nice.
Oh wait, does that slow it down too?
And then...
Oh shit!
Okay, nice.
Alright, we're okay.
It's fine!
It's just like three damage.
We'll be fine.
And then we'll lock him in here.
So he can't get...
He can't touch me.
Alright.
Guys, we don't need...
Wait, I really like the slow.
Cause like...
Now I don't have to...
I can be even more lazy with my reaction time.
That's like my favorite part.
Yay!
Alright.
Weapon upgrade.
Wait!
Vampire!
I can never die!
But no longer strikes behind your...
Wait, I can strike behind me?
Wait!
Vampire!
I can never die then!
Oh my god, everything goes for Doki.
I'm so happy.
Always.
Wait, who's this?
Hammer time.
It was an accident!
I'm so sorry!
It was glowing!
Hello?
There's a spider!
Oh!
You're the new Medusa!
That people wanna bang!
What are you doing here?
It's nothing silly.
I can always make more perfectly good silk.
I can always see you.
It's our first time we met.
Sorry about all this.
I think we'll soon be seeing...
Please no.
Look, if people wanted to bang a snake head, people would bang a fucking spider.
You can't judge.
Truly.
Why then I'll get out of your hair.
You have to go.
But first, you have to try on one of these.
And don't worry about any wear and tear.
I have plenty more money.
What am I trying on?
What is it?
Don a 50 plus outfit that makes you restore 2?
Don a 40 that makes you restore?
Don that makes you channel?
Wait!
Isn't channel better?
Can I get channel?
It's 40% faster.
Or temporary health?
No?
Is mana actually better?
I don't know.
2?
Oh okay.
The mana one is actually really good.
I'll do 2 then.
I'll get more mana.
Oh my.
This is beautiful.
Thank you.
Oh no.
No!
It's ok.
I have a vampire.
Did not grab my HP back?
No!
I lost a bit of my fucking armor!
Alright, let's see.
Well, we need max HP.
Oh, I'm so sad.
I'm so sad.
Okay.
Oh god.
Oh wait, I got my HP back!
I did it!
I got it back!
Okay, nice.
We're doing it.
We're actually getting better.
And then... I can't believe it!
Doki actually improving in video games?
Oh my god, the world truly is ending.
Okay, nice.
What even is my special?
Wait, do I not have a special yet?
I don't think I have a special.
Alright, 75.
Apparently I need more ash.
Alright.
Doki properly using game mechanics.
What a fucking gamer.
I really do like the slow though.
The slow is actually so helpful.
Whoops.
Oh wait, that hits?
Oh shit, wait!
No wonder I could...
I'm just saying, I'm just naturally talented.
I can't believe it!
Every attack just magically hit!
That's crazy!
Alright, I'm just gonna be here.
Guys.
Just be here and then slowly just hitting things up here.
There we go.
Nice.
Oh shit!
Okay, I did not expect him to fucking show up next to me.
It's fine though.
Everything's fine.
Pew!
Just sending an orb of death over.
Yay!
Is that it?
Just slowly sending an orb of death.
Just don't touch me.
Yay!
It's okay, I can recharge.
Nice.
Use this game on my fucking life.
What's this?
Wait, what?
I don't know.
I actually don't know what that was.
Oh, what was that?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Nope.
Oh, okay.
I thought that would get closer.
Not gonna lie.
Okay, then we'll kill him with this.
It's okay.
It slowed.
Now kill him with this.
And then this.
And then that should be the last guy.
Yay!
That was not the last guy.
Not yay.
Fine.
I have mana regen.
Alright.
Oh god.
Almost got hit by that.
Okay.
Whoa!
Fucking fight me like a fucking four-legged beta.
Alright.
That should hit them.
Oh!
No!
My honor!
Oh, I'm ready for HP.
That's fine.
It's okay.
I already got my HP back.
But not even Athena knows what.
His assaults on Olympus always fail.
Even if they've kept us occupied.
What's his next move?
What is his next move?
Alright.
Your attack deals more damage in larger area.
Your sprint is faster and flicks days on nearby foes.
Okay.
This would be helpful if I actually used my sprint.
After you take damage, your foe takes damage and you flick days on...
Wait!
Wouldn't lights might be good too?
One?
Your attack deals more damage?
Okay.
We'll do one.
I see more ones in chat.
Oh, Ashe time!
Okay.
I can get to the witch again.
You know what?
I bet you I'm gonna beat the witch right here.
Whoa.
Okay.
I'm gonna put this out.
So...
If I keep using this, they'll never get close to me to hit me.
See?
Oh my god.
I'm so fucking smart.
And now I'll just regen.
And I'll just do this again.
Oh, wait.
What do you mean you can't?
You can or you won't.
Alright.
Nice.
Can't touch me.
Yay!
I don't need to use charge normal if I can just kill them.
See?
I recharge.
Why would I need to use charge...
When I can just use charge normal when I can just do this all the time?
Yay!
Okay.
Guys, I think I cannot just do this all the time.
I'm sorry!
Guys, I think I figured out that this game will not let me use charge all the time.
I can't believe it.
Getting punished?
Say it ain't so!
What was this?
It's upgrade, right?
Should I get health or upgrades, chat?
Spam magic bead, like...
What would be better?
Upgrade?
Alright.
Upgrade.
Yay!
Not yay!
Okay.
Yay!
It was in fact not yay.
Maybe I can just stay up here.
Okay.
So then she won't touch me here.
See?
I can cast.
Normally.
I don't abuse my power ups.
Noverstrike, Geyser ring.
Wait!
That's so good!
Okay.
But that's 25, 35.
Wait.
Should I get Geyser ring?
I feel like Geyser... or attack.
Yeah.
I feel like I'm using Geyser ring so much.
Shop.
Do I have money?
I have 182.
I still don't know what that is though.
Alright.
Shop or whatever the fuck that is.
I still have no idea.
Shop?
Alright.
Shop time.
I have enough for actual stuff now.
Hello!
Ooh!
Poseidon.
I mean he was already sort of a smuggler.
I'll buy you a first place.
Your special hits pose with splash that knocks other foes away.
After you enter location Prime 30 to reduce any damage you would take.
Whenever you claim a minor fine or similar research a copy may appear.
I feel like all these are terrible.
Maybe one?
I think that two and three seems fucking terrible.
Terrible.
God, you're so hot when you're just a placeholder.
Good talk, Chiron.
Alright, Hecate time.
Hecate time.
I'm back!
It's seasonably cold.
Or perhaps it is as Demeter desires.
She aids you, does she not?
She does.
I mean, all the gods and goddesses are helping me.
Have you had opportunity to speak with her about me and all that's transpired?
No.
I've been a bit preoccupied.
At least here, Demeter shall be able to cool her wrath against me for keeping you a secret for so long.
Alright.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
It's okay.
There's nothing she can do to me, cause I have...
Oh, I missed.
There's nothing she can do to me for real, cause I didn't miss!
This time!
Nice magic.
Magic time.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Magic time.
Oh, fuck!
Okay, it's okay.
I have armor.
Nice.
And then...
Magic.
And I'll just keep spamming that and then now I...
Oh, it's her!
Because she's talking!
Oh, shit.
Not my armor.
Oh, this is not good.
I lost my armor cause I was fucking around too much.
Nice.
And then slow.
And I'll just keep spamming that here.
Okay.
Nice.
Wait, she has armor.
That's not fair.
Where's my armor?
I'm a witch too, aren't I?
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
And then...
Oh, this is Touhou.
I don't like this.
I hate Touhou.
I hate...
Okay.
I'm not good at Touhou, please!
Why is the first boss Touhou?
It's not fair!
Oh, I ran out of mana.
Oh, God.
Oh!
Okay.
We're fine.
I have the reaction time.
It's fine.
We're halfway there.
Nice.
Just gonna draw back.
And then go!
Alright.
It's okay.
We're making good progress.
The moment she talks, I know it's the...
Oh, fuck!
This is Touhou!
This is the real one!
I got the real Hecate!
Let's see you with age.
Yes!
Whoa!
Evaded.
I don't know, girl!
I evaded it!
Okay.
I can just do this.
I can just spam this.
There you go.
What's she gonna do?
Hit back?
I can literally just spam this.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
That's right!
Can't touch me now!
Oh, whoa, wait, wait, wait!
What's that?
No!
The sheep!
Okay.
I'm a sheep now.
Alright.
That was a little fucking bullshit.
Not gonna lie.
I can't even run as a sheep.
Hello?
No!
That's not fair!
Okay.
We're okay.
Wait!
If I lose my armor, I don't get my recharge of mana?
Why did nobody tell me instead of making me read?
.
People could have told me this!
If I knew, I wouldn't have fucked around!
You guys knew that!
I wouldn't have fucked around!
With my armor!
Okay.
Now I know though.
Now I know.
Oh, shit.
Which one is it though?
It's her.
Alright.
That's all I'm seeing.
If I knew this earlier, I would have...
I definitely would have not messed about.
Turkey Cathering.
Yay!
I did it!
Yeah!
What about me?
Continue now your task.
I shall await your safe return.
Wait, I did it!
I told you guys!
My second run and I already defeated Hecate!
I passed the test.
I did it!
Yoki, you stand still.
You can still regen.
Yeah, but that requires me to stand still.
There's a problem there already!
.
Okay.
Nice.
First try.
Does this regen my heals?
Oh, nice.
I got my heals back.
Yay!
Why won't you and your abs join me?
What's this?
The Rim of Oceanus?
This is like an ocean.
Hello?
Who are you?
You're a long way from the Crossroads, Charlie.
Strife Incarnate.
So, this is where the real action is, huh?
The game?
The RTS?
Or should I still be practicing?
Things took a turn, Eris.
You know how it goes.
Now, if you'll excuse me, I have some urgent business to attend to.
What's that gun?
They had guns back then?
Always in such a rush.
I'd really hate to slow you down.
Though, let's hang out sometime, okay?
Have a great night.
Oh, one last thing.
What'd she do to me?
Blessed by strife?
Yeah, what did she do to me?
Uh...
What did she do?
Wait, it didn't even say what she did.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Oh my god!
Okay.
I still don't know what she did!
She debuffed me?
How do I check?
Wait, how do I check the debuff?
Oh my god, they're so strong.
This is actually not fair.
Press B?
Whoa!
Guys!
Wait, what the fuck?
Don't even press B!
B actually does not...
Guys, if you guys did not know, B does not pause the game.
Oh my fucking god.
I lost so much HP!
Because I fucking pressed B!
Holy shit.
Fuck you guys.
I can't believe it.
That's my fucking stream, right?
Okay.
Alright.
Your phone deals 20% damage.
Okay.
Alright.
That's fucked up.
But okay.
It wasn't me.
Yeah, totally wasn't you.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe you guys fucked me up like this.
Alright, streamer.
Of course I was gonna press B!
I literally heard, press B!
And I was like, oh, B?
I wonder what B does!
If you tell me to press B, of course I'm gonna press it!
Like, it's just simple!
Simple button pressing!
Streamer sees press B, she presses.
No one told... said it was a...
It's cause I looked at it, it should be a pause!
But it should be!
That's why I don't understand why it was a pause.
I could not!
Okay, there we go.
I'll just spam this.
Yay!
Oh my god, they're so strong!
Oh, this is not good.
Yeah, alright, we're gonna...
We're gonna make sure they don't touch me.
By shooting them here.
Oh, this is good.
My attacks are really strong right now.
I'll put this here so they don't, like, touch me.
They don't get close enough to touch me.
Okay.
Nice.
And then we'll get that out of the way.
Woo!
Alright, we're good.
Yay, money!
For me!
I love money!
They're so strong though.
Uh... I have enough for shop.
Personal space deployed.
My five meters.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, that's the shield!
Do I have enough?
Wait, I think I have enough.
I have enough to buy a shield.
Your sprint forms a cyclone.
You enter a location.
Prime a barrier that absorbs one.
Wait, there it is!
There's the weed killer!
You guys said the weed killer is really good, right?
Yeah.
Bum, bum.
Sprint or weed killer, guys.
But this one's not epic.
Oh, so the...
Oh!
And do I do one?
It's better when it's rare?
Okay, I'll do the sprint then.
And we'll see.
What the...
Wait, would this armor be my mana regen armor?
Is this gonna be my mana regen armor, guys?
Or like, is it like a different armor?
No?
No!
Why didn't she make me better?
Better armor!
Oh, we'll just buy power up then.
Just extra health.
Alright, we'll just buy power up.
Nova Strike.
Alright.
Whoa!
Wait, that's pretty fucking cool.
How do I get to the other side?
Oh, I dash.
Sorry, I forgot about like basic stuff.
I don't want to fight a boss, so I'm gonna go to Poseidon.
I'm doing the bare minimum.
Oh, shit!
Alright, and then cast!
Whoa!
Get away from me!
No touchy!
Alright, nice.
And then...
I want to be max HP, so I'm gonna max this out.
Oh, wait, they're stuck!
Wait, what?
I didn't get max HP.
How could that be?
Where's my...
Oh!
Whoa!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
No!
No touchy!
No touchy, guys!
Wait, where's my vampire?
Oh, God.
Oh, my God!
Oh, gosh!
Oh, no touch!
No touch!
Oh, my God!
What?
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no!
Okay.
It's fine.
Oh, this is not fine.
This is not fine.
Only on charge attacks and only on kills?
Okay.
That's...
That is also fine.
So I'm just gonna make it so...
Okay.
I need to...
I need to make sure I don't get hit by that.
All right.
There.
There's no way he can hit me from back here.
I'll just recharge my mana.
Hello, guys.
Hello.
Fancy seeing you all here.
And then charge.
And then I'll just be here.
Okay.
And then I'll just wait until I charge that up.
And I'll wait until I charge that up.
And I should get my HP.
Wait.
It didn't give me the HP.
It's what normal cast doesn't work on special.
Oh.
Guys.
I learned.
I finally read the right one.
It only took me a bit, but I read the right one.
The left click.
It's left clicks.
All right.
After you enter a location, prime, where you claim a minor fine, a similar resource or code, your splash effects from Poseidon also inflict slips on foe.
Oh, they can knock further away after you enter a location.
Two?
Double up?
Okay.
We'll go with two.
Ash time.
Okay.
We're going to go with two.
Shelf act.
Shell backs?
Why bad?
I can just spam this and then.
Yay.
Oh, it's because they're in the shell.
That's why bad.
Yeah, but I can do this.
I mean, I can just do this.
I hold HP now, so I don't care.
Yay!
So easy.
Easiest fucking game of my life.
Oh.
Yeah, you can't fucking touch me!
Okay, wait.
Okay, give me a sec.
I just realized that...
I have no- Oh!
No no no no no!
You touched me!
Okay, nope.
This is bad.
I need mana.
Guys, give me a sec.
Please don't hit me.
I'm just gonna get some mana real quick.
Just be a bit.
Alright, nice.
I got- Wait, what?
He blocked me!
It's like going into the shell actually blocks damage!
No!
I'm fucking around!
Okay, I'm not fucking around anymore.
No more- No more fucking around.
Alright guys, I can't fuck around anymore.
I took too much damage.
Alright, we're gonna stay here.
In this chill.
We're just gonna chill back here.
She jinxed herself.
I realize...
I realize it's not fun in games anymore.
They hit me.
Yay!
Oh, ash.
It's right there.
Couldn't find it earlier.
I feel like I don't need coins.
I build up enough like coins...
from this.
Oh!
Okay, nice.
Alright, we broke this.
So I'm gonna do this here.
And then...
Nope.
And then that should...
give me my HP back.
Is that it?
Where are they?
Oh!
He's lost!
All his friends are dead!
Wait, he still has a friend!
He's not technically lost!
Okay.
I really like the...
I really like the snare.
It's actually so convenient.
Yay!
Full HP!
Okay.
Get away from me.
Wait, wait!
How does that hit me?
Oh!
It's the arrows!
It's always the fucking arrows!
Oh!
Okay.
I got hit by the arrows accidentally.
What the fuck?
What?
How did I lose so much?
What hit me?
Okay.
Actually, what hit me?
Oh, God.
I don't even know what hit me!
Uh...
Your special hits a force with splash that knocks.
The attack deals more damage in a larger area.
Uh...
Those three orbs?
There were orbs?
I couldn't even see it!
Oh, it's a debuff!
I forgot!
Every time I get hit...
Fucking arrows!
No more...
There's a reason why nobody invites you to anything.
No one likes you!
Okay.
After we...
Okay, we'll do that.
Oh, hey!
Double up!
Wait, that is so good!
Uh...
We can add more damage?
Wait, we got another one!
We're so lucky!
Um...
Again?
Gotcha paid off!
Yay!
Gambling!
Hahaha!
Um...
Okay.
Uh...
One?
Three?
Uh...
Oh my gosh!
I don't know!
They all look so good!
Two?
Nova strikes for me.
Two.
Okay.
We'll go with two.
Alright.
Okay.
We're gonna...
Ash time!
Ash!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Okay.
Maybe...
No!
Fuck!
Oh, no!
Okay.
Maybe now?
Nice.
Gives me a little bit of my HP back.
That's...
Oh!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
No!
Oh, God!
Oh!
That is not good!
Okay.
No.
I need to stand still.
Please.
Guys, I need to...
No!
Please!
Let me stand still!
I need recharge!
Okay.
Oh, God.
Just a little bit.
Please, just let me recharge just a little bit.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Recharge.
Let me recharge just a little bit.
These guys are actual, like, griefers.
Not gonna lie.
They're actual griefers.
Oh, it's because he's like a mini-boss!
That makes sense.
Wait, I can farm him.
I can stand still and farm him.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
All right.
Yes!
Got my HP back.
Okay.
This is actually good for me.
These guys can give me so much HP.
I'm gonna go back to the base.
And then I can just, like, put the snare out so they can't touch me here.
All right.
Nice.
And then snare!
Okay.
Here we go.
And then I'll just snare them here.
Snare!
Wait, I know the stride now!
Okay.
Nice.
Look at that strategy.
I told you I could use my brain.
Man.
It's only when it matters.
And a lot of times it doesn't matter.
It's not my fault that, like, I'm always on power save mode, guys.
Just because I'm on power save mode doesn't mean I don't have a brain.
Snare is actually so good.
Whoa!
Okay.
That's not good, though.
I just need to make sure they don't get near me.
Because they're so good.
There's so many of these little fucking guys.
Why are they still existing?
Holy shit.
Okay.
All right.
I'm just gonna put a snare here so I can be at peace.
Is it because these are still alive?
Oh my god.
There's so many birdfish!
I felt like I just killed, like, a million of them and now they're, like, an endangered species.
Oh my god.
Easy.
Yay!
Yeah, there's, like, so many...
Oh!
Gambling!
Uh...
I think I can do the shop.
Actually, I feel like I need more HP.
Uh...
Shop or HP, guys?
I feel like I might need more HP because, like, uh...
Uh...
Yeah, we don't have a lot of HP.
We only had one HP upgrade so far.
Oh my god.
Bonus.
Gambling?
Aww.
No Gamba.
Alright, we have 162 gold, but no Gamba time.
Who are these guys?
An ever-present song compels the nightmare-bringing princess ever forward towards the beauty deeper into the abyss.
Boss 2 already?
Of course, because I'm a gamer.
She's not feeding the allegations!
She's a gamer.
Gamer!
Who's she?
Is it Rockband?
I'm Hades too.
Hey!
That means they're really good performers.
That their fans are willing to die for them.
Yeah!
Exactly!
How dare you!
Alright.
Can I cast her?
Okay guys!
Cast does not work on them!
Okay.
Well, that's good to- OH MY GOD!
WHAT?!
Guys.
Can I kill her?
WHAT?!
Okay.
Does cast work on her?
Okay, cast works on her!
Alright, that's good.
That's good.
We know.
Okay, I'll just cast her.
Oh, no!
Wait, this is a bit difficult.
Wait, this is actually pretty difficult, guys.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Wait, wait, I'm fucking dead!
Oh my god!
Okay, I'm so confused.
Oh, I don't like this level.
Guys.
I actually...
Wait, wait, a minute.
Wait, a minute.
Wait a min...
Wait a minute.
Oh no.
Oh no!
No!
This boss fucking sucks.
I had one fucking timing.
No!
I hate that.
This is my new hate.
I hate this boss.
It's brooding time.
Bro, I've never hated... You know what?
I hate boss fights where it's not one person.
They just add two more...
They add more bosses in a one boss fight game.
And like... It's... Just to spike the difficulty.
I hate that mechanic so much.
I think that's a fucking bullshit boss battle.
Because you have to pay attention to three different bosses that have their own fucking pattern.
That is randomized.
Because there's no way that they're gonna walk the same path.
They're gonna walk similar together.
Hey Dora.
Skill issue.
It's not a skill issue!
It's a hate!
Alright.
Bye Dora.
Is he like my friend?
Is she like... Like those like... Familiars?
Is she like a familiar?
Oh, the cauldron's ready?
Wait, what's this?
Beta intervention.
Persuade the retro broker to appear with whom you may trade for various resources.
For those who know...
Receive... Wait, I want this!
Mostly used for unlock... Yeah!
We want pickaxe!
Dark of chaos.
Light of...
Give me pickaxe!
Heed now my will.
Alex, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So might it be.
Oh!
I got pickaxe now.
Okay, and then... I guess we can summon him.
I'm ready.
By blood and darkness, let my will be done.
Yeah!
Alright.
Welcome to the crossroads.
What is he gonna sell me?
Okay, let me talk to the placeholder guy.
Salute.
Beware, mistress.
Oh no, that's Hecate.
I'm just a woman anyway.
Sorry.
I swear the boat guy and her have like similar costumes.
Maybe it's because they're both wearing all black.
At least our cauldrons finally purified.
Praise the fates.
Speaking of which, are you as yet considering an invocation to them?
I have my doubts that they would listen even now.
If there's any chance the three fates shall aid us, I'll take it.
Thank you for preparing things for me.
Though I'm well sure that I will.
I ought to freshly picked reagents still.
Mmm.
I'd offer such reagents if I could, but as you venture past this glade, look carefully along your path...
Aren't they related?
Well, one's a witch and the other one's dead.
I don't know.
Yes, headmistress.
Yay!
What are you selling?
Hailbroker.
Oh!
Ash and psych.
Wait, what's fate fabric?
What's fate fabric, guys?
I still don't know what the psych is for.
What is this for?
It hasn't told me what psych is for.
What is it?
E to C?
Yeah, fuck her!
Nobody likes her.
Wait, why is she trying to slow me down?
Yeah, I thought we were supposed to be really good friends and roommates.
Why is she gonna keep doing this to me?
Why can't we just tell her to stop?
Somebody tell her to stop!
Like, what?
She's a little quirky.
Just slap her!
Be like, bad!
Bad, Iris!
Oh, so Kronos took over Hades.
Wait, so...
Does that mean no one can die now?
Because there's no...
No one can die now because there's no, like, after life?
We do a little bit of tomfoolery.
Wait, is there anything... did I miss anything here?
Can I still talk to Hypnos?
No, okay.
He's just leaping.
He's just eepy.
Death to Kronos.
Oh yeah, where do we go now?
Yes and no?
They died, they just don't stay dead?
Oh, wait, that's good!
Then we should, like, let Kronos still be the house of Hades.
Uh... well, we need regen.
And then...
Let's see, after every...
Your new Akina card requires more graphs than you have available.
So you cannot be activated.
Oh, that's what Grasp is!
Top right corner to increase your Grasp or de...
Oh!
We're not having a Grasp?
I want more Grasp.
Okay, let me...
Now they turn into ghosts?
Wait, then that's good!
I get to haunt people.
I'll be like, you fuck with me, I'm now gonna haunt you forever.
Grasp is psyche.
Wait, but I could save him.
I'm gonna save him for your Fabra.
Firmly grasp it.
Alright, let's see.
Just breathe.
Uh, gain plus two Grasp.
Greater Grasp lets you activate more...
Wait, how much do I need?
Oh, I need 12.
Uh...
I guess I could...
Can I get rid of something?
I like the move slower.
I feel like...
Well, I can't activate anything yet.
I'll just do all these first.
Just breathe.
Each Knight with one Death Defiance after every...
Wait, I want to save for a Death Defiance actually.
Wait, do I already have it?
No, I'm too low.
It's beyond my Grasp.
I could turn this off and put this...
I feel like if I turn...
Yeah, I'm gonna turn this off.
And then we can have it.
I already have regen.
Regen seems a lot better.
I'm gonna do...
Where...
Oh, wait.
Can I...
Do I have another weapon now?
I do!
I don't!
Okay.
It's the pick.
Alright.
Nice.
Do I have it equipped yet?
I do.
Okay.
I need to find these.
Wait, I can upgrade my Grasp?
I don't have enough...
I don't have enough Psyche for that.
Yeah, I need 40.
I have 20?
So I need to start farming Psyche now.
Yeah, but I want to save up for the Faded Fabric.
I don't know what it is, but it sounds fucking cool.
Why is it the same thing?
Does he give me anything new?
No, I just want to talk.
The value of shadowy denizen of the underworld comes with certain perks, young one.
Take for instance how when you dash, nothing can touch you.
We are the unseen.
At one with the darkness...
Yeah, the infinity frames.
... would repeat anything.
Yes.
But only for a moment, and even then, I can't prevail by dodging all night long.
Yeah, I'd do it all the time if I was you.
See the little trail when you dash.
Once it snaps back, you're good to go again.
Uhh.
Huh?
Okay.
That's interesting.
What's this?
Restore my magic.
Okay.
Do I have to look at the scenery again for more lore?
Oh, so I have to go through all of this...
to reach Olympus.
Am I going to Olympus?
I assume it's Olympus, right?
So pretty.
I wonder if this is a placeholder.
Because I feel like they could definitely improve this one.
Because, I don't know.
It sort of looks like a sketch.
It does sort of look like a placeholder.
Alright, down I'll go.
Wait, no, you're right.
No, down is up.
Guys.
Oh my god, YouTube, please.
Okay, the only other thing I know about Hades 2 is her.
Aphrodite.
Guys!
Guys, calm...
Guys, guys, calm down.
Guys, let me...
Guys, calm down.
Calm down, everybody.
Calm down, everyone.
Calm down!
I doubtless this one knows hatred, not just love.
And the name of Hades.
Olympus, accept this message.
It's her.
You're gorgeous.
You look like you can break some hearts even without my aid.
Oh, your brother would be so proud.
Her eyes are up there, chat!
Her eyes are up there!
Your special deals more damage...
to nearby foes.
Your cast...
Whoa!
If you each encounter one foe is always weak, you gradually restore...
Oh!
Near weak foes.
Wait, I like that.
Glamour gain.
Wait, what do you mean?
What do you mean, Hades 2?
Why do you want to learn more from her?
Okay.
Nice.
Everyone is gonna...
Oh my gosh, the regen is actually so clutch, not gonna lie.
Looks like a new path out.
Don't forget the silver?
What does the silver look like though?
Like...
Near all of the near endless pathways and suffocating Erebus...
Oh, I see it!
It has like moon rocks!
...and very scarce are those who can navigate...
All rocks come from the moon.
I don't know if you guys know that.
...to figure out.
Silver.
But how much can I collect?
Whoa!
Collecting moon rocks!
That's where rocks are born, chat.
The moon like cries and then like the tears are the rocks that come out of the moon ducts and then it falls on the earth.
Today I learned.
Is that interesting fact, guys?
I learned that like...
I learned that like in elementary school.
From my science teacher.
Every time you see a rock, just remember it came from the moon.
Hahaha!
Astronomy with Doki!
Uh...
I definitely need heals.
I'm like 30 HP.
What's this?
No!
Okay, Majora's Mask...
No, no.
Majora's Mask is different.
Majora's Mask, the moon is trying to kill you.
But like...
But like in the real world...
The moon is just crying.
Because it's sad.
It's sad because it wants to date the earth.
But the earth like always was like...
I don't know, man.
Like...
I just see you as a really good friend, you know?
I don't know.
I don't think we can make it work.
It's just gonna ruin our friendship.
Alright.
Money or heart?
I feel like more heart.
We don't need money.
Sad moon!
That's why...
So then the moon is like the creepy stalker.
That wouldn't leave the earth alone.
Because the moon keeps following them every...
Every rotation.
And the earth was like...
Bro, come on, man.
Hahaha!
Moon-chan got...
Wait, the hunt is on?
Who the fuck is hunting me?
I'm here talking about my...
My earth slash moon fanfiction.
Oh!
Wait, Artemis?
Is that Artemis?
Artemis, help me!
Nice.
Artemis, is she helping me?
Oh, that's nice though.
Yeah, she's helping me!
Nice!
I can continue my earth slash moon fanfiction.
And then like...
So like...
And then there was like a mistake that they made one night.
Where like...
Um...
Where like the moon tried to make the earth jealous by...
Artemis!
By trying to hook up with the sun.
And they're like...
Wait, let's get some light first.
Hello, Artemis!
Sister?
I'm sorry.
I'm coming to see you.
Hey, she's so different.
And her couple name is Eclipse!
Alright.
Ozu, at least, may take critical damage.
Aramiel...
Cast?
Wait, wouldn't that... would lethal snare be good?
Because I'm snaring a lot too.
I feel like.
Or unless we get death warrant.
I feel like snare would be better.
Just because I'm always snaring.
And then it may take critical damage.
Yeah, I use snare a lot.
Alright, we're gonna go with snare.
Bye Artemis!
We're gonna need Sykes so we can grab more.
Why can't she do that all the time?
I don't understand.
She should be helping me all the time.
Because we're sisters.
Black, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
And then the Urf has to like...
Wait!
Armor time!
Wait, not armor time?
Oh, I found it!
Wait, does that mean...
Wait, that was easy.
Does that mean these are monsters?
I assume these were monsters, right?
Yeah.
Alright, I did it.
First try!
Fistball, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
The moon orbits the earth, but the Urf orbits the sun.
Love triangle, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
Lost core, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you!
The Urf and moon banged once 4.5 billion years ago and learned that they weren't meant for each other.
It was like a mistake, you know?
So the... and that's...
The earth knew it was a mistake, but he can't let go.
But the moon was like, no, give me one more chance, earth-kun!
Oh, shit!
I just want more money!
That's fine.
I just want more money.
So we're just gonna do this for the...
It's just for the money, guys!
Like, I already fucking...
Oh, guys, why did I do this for the money?!
Okay, this is actually pretty bad.
Okay, I... I realize I don't have vampire...
No, it does not mean to fucking kill this guy too!
Okay...
Oh!
Shop, shop, shop!
No!
No, no, it's locked!
Okay.
Okay, this is bad.
This is bad.
I forgot I don't have vampire.
So, like, this is not as fun.
Alright.
Nice.
We'll go get Psyche.
Actually, we'll go grab...
We'll go to the shop.
Alright.
No!
I don't have enough money!
But we'll upgrade, I guess.
I recall that his plans to conquer Olympus is sensitive work.
No.
Oh.
Does Corina want to be the Titan Lord?
Or are we just gonna help him.
Alright, let's grab the Moon Tears again.
Yay!
Get this.
More Moon Tears!
Okay, let's snare them here so they can't hurt me.
And then we'll use that.
And then we'll have money.
And then we're just gonna get them away from us.
Oh, wait.
That's fine, they're dead anyway.
Yay!
Oh, he's the weaker one.
The weaker child.
Nobody loves you because you're weak as fuck.
We're just gonna get rid of the spinners.
And then the little guys here.
We'll stun them.
Unlock them.
Nice.
Wait, what are you doing?
Why are you watching me?
Go help!
Nice.
Fire time!
Woah, what?
Who's older?
Hestia or Aphrodite?
Wait, does that mean Aphrodite is all plastic?
Is that what she... Is that what Grand...
Grand Fire is trying to apply?
... but give up one...
Hestia's like, no fuck her.
Give me...
Give me your glamour.
Alright.
You cast repeatedly Scorched Foes.
Your special inflicts foes.
Let's see.
Do I do...
I use cast a lot.
We'll use cast.
Flame of the hearth.
Ashroq's glamour.
I feel like I should keep getting more psyche.
Because I feel like I have not been farming psyche and I really need more psyche so I can have more cards to use.
Alright, let's go.
We'll do this.
And bam.
I need to be more careful because like uh...
I definitely don't have vampire anymore.
So like...
So... so like...
This is actually life or death now.
Alright, nice.
Now we're just gonna get these guys out of the way.
Alright, snare them.
Alright, nice.
And then poof.
Easy.
Yeah!
I still don't know what the...
Oh, this is magic.
Okay, so I rather...
I rather just...
Wait, does that...
This makes my max magic stronger.
But who cares about that?
It's all about power-ups.
Uh...
Okay...
And then...
Line this up real fast.
And then line this up.
I don't know.
I feel like the common enemies are easier.
But by fucking god.
The bosses are so difficult now.
I feel like level...
The first level and the second level bosses were not as hard as this.
Definitely feels like common enemies are easy.
Bosses are hard.
Yeah, the titans are like...
They might be pre-gods and goddesses, but there's a reason why the titans are all died out.
Alright.
Wait, Lucid... Wait!
While standing in your cast...
Wait, what?
Exchange?
Heroic?
But it's heroic.
While standing in your cast, gradually restores...
What was glamour again?
Uh, do I get this?
Okay, I don't need glamour.
Uh...
Wait, I want this because I want the fabric.
Okay.
That's good, right?
Oop.
That's right.
You can't touch me.
He can touch me.
Alright.
Nice.
So I can just stand here and farm.
I can literally stand here and just farm this, right?
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Okay, and then...
Let's see.
I'll cast and then... Oh!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Alright.
Nope.
Alright, and then cast.
Oh god!
Okay.
Just keep casting.
Oh my god!
Wait, this... Oh shit!
No!
Okay.
Anyway, I can keep farming this.
Because all I do is just... I do infinite cast and then I just farm it inside my cast.
Yeah, I have the regen.
Oh, I need to grab the...
I need to grab the... the...
the thingy.
Uhhhhhh...
I don't need magic anymore.
Because like, I have infinite cast.
Yeah.
And then I'll just do this.
And then I can cast this.
And I'll just stand here.
And then...
Wait, how do I lose it?
How did I lose my magic if I'm infinitely charging?
And I do this.
Fucking easy.
Oh my gosh.
Easiest game of my life.
Yeah, I can just kill all of them here.
I don't even need a sprint.
Hello granny, I'm back!
Your attack inflicts scorch.
Your fire launches a fiery projectile but uses...
my special...
Whenever scorched, afflicted foes are slain.
I have scorch, right?
I've cast scorch!
Wait, this is good!
Natural gas with my...
cast.
Uh...
Wasn't it?
Because then I have like...
my cast plus...
Yeah!
Natural gas plus my cast.
You're not charging special use... Yeah, exactly.
I still don't know how to use my special.
Do I even have a special?
I don't have enough for...
the shop though.
I only have 142.
So maybe I should go for an upgrade?
I actually don't have enough for the shop.
I have only 100.
Wait.
Oh, this is my special.
Oh, whoops.
Whoops.
Uh...
I should go fruit.
Yeah, special is my...
I keep forgetting that special is my range attack.
Oh my god!
I can make a better heroic!
I'm gonna go with that.
Alright, it's Hecate time.
Okay!
So I have to kill my...
my... my...
spiritual mom.
It's me!
You surpassed me before, yet I wonder...
Was it your mastery over our craft?
Or did the fates themselves perhaps provide a little...
nudge?
Come, headmistress.
If I could be provoked that easily, I'd stand no chance at all.
This is easy.
I'm heroic now.
I might not have regen, but I have regen and mana.
... comes to those in no position to receive it.
Show me your victory.
It was not a fluke.
It was all a skill.
Alright, here we go.
See?
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
And then I do this.
Okay!
Okay, that's not fair.
That's not fair!
She doesn't get stuck in my cast!
Oh god.
Okay.
And then I'll do this.
And then...
Okay, that is...
No, that's a fake.
That's a fake!
That's also a fake!
That's real.
He's real.
He's real!
No!
Guys, I think I...
Guys, regen might have been a crutch.
Just a maybe.
I'm not sure yet.
It's a maybe.
Oh!
No, no, no, no, no, no!
We're fine.
I can run.
Okay, and then we're gonna get rid of you.
And...
We're gonna get rid of you.
And then we're gonna get rid of you.
You're weak as hell.
Easy.
And then you're gonna be over here, right?
Right?
You're gonna...
You're gonna be over here, right?
Oh no!
No!
No, no, no, no, no!
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
I'm trying!
No, that's not the real one.
Of course I chose the non-real ones!
Of course!
Alright, just half HP.
That's good.
No, no, no, no, no, no!
Let me cast!
Okay, and then... cast!
Caaast!
Okay, and then we go this way.
Easy.
Cast.
I'll just stay here in my cast circle.
It's like the...
It's like that circle in Spongebob.
Oh, nice.
There it is.
It's like the Spongebob circle.
The sand bear can't get me.
No!
How do I dodge that?
That's not fair!
For the sea bears.
Sorry, it's the sea bears.
Like, how do I fucking dodge that?
No!
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh no.
I'm 37 HP.
Oh gosh.
The witch.
Get the last witch.
Alright.
No, no, no, no, no.
Gotta get rid of all the witches.
Okay.
And then...
Please be over here.
Please.
Nice.
Oh!
No, no, no, no, no!
No!
I got stuck!
Is this the right one?
Nope, it's not.
This guy.
Okay.
It's fine.
I can just farm this here.
Oh!
Nope, I cannot.
Yes, I can.
Nope, I cannot!
Oh!
My god!
Guys, I made a mistake.
Guys, I might have made just a little miscalculations.
Oh god.
Oh.
Okay.
I'll just keep casting right here.
I'll just save my little safe zone.
No, no, no, no, no.
My little safe zone right here.
Come on!
Keep casting in your safe zone!
Oh god.
Please!
Please.
No!
Fuck!
Right here.
Come on.
No, no, no, no, no, no!
I threw!
I dashed it!
I actually dashed it!
No!
I got greedy!
I was like, I got this.
Who the fuck is this child?
I can't believe I dashed into it.
I can't fucking believe it.
It was literally 1 HP.
I can't believe it.
I choked.
I can't believe...
I dashed into it and all I got was luck.
I dashed into the floor.
Oh my god.
Looks so...
Fucking... I don't know.
She looks so...
So like...
Not their child.
Looks so round.
Yeah.
The art style is like...
I guess it's the art style.
...
The art style looks like different from like the usual art style.
... The art style looks like different from like the usual art style.
She looks like Steven Universe.
Hey, I found you.
Got you, Hecate!
You're dead!
... Got me, you did, ... Got me, you did, ... but I dare say I can escape your clutches yet.
... but I dare say I can escape your clutches yet.
Whoa!
Wait, she's gone!
Where did she go?
Cool.
Odysseus, where did she go?
Alright.
Yeah, where is she?
Where are you?
Wait, if I was a... I'm a goddess.
Oh, there she is!
I see her!
Got you again!
I'm the best hide and seek finder there is!
Wait, is she also a Titaness?
Or are they roleplaying?
I thought Hecate was a witch.
Where is she?
Where did she go?
Hello?
Hecate?
Hecate, where are you?
Oh, they're LARPing.
Oh, I see.
Ye olde.
Ancient LARP.
Where did she go?
Oh, there she is!
I see her.
Hello, Hecate!
Oh, she is a Titan.
I thought they were all dead, except for Cronos.
Like, gods and goddesses killed off all the Titans.
I've not heard your laughter before.
Reminded me of your mother.
A much preferable sound to that of grief.
I promise not to cry again.
I still get sad.
Oh no.
Why are you sad?
Your parents are still alive, we think.
Why is she abs?
Be a witch is hard work, okay?
She did not skip the gym.
But you never cry, Hecate.
And I wish to become strong like you.
So that I might find Cronos and destroy him for what he's done.
And then...
And I shall do everything in my power to prepare you.
So that you may succeed where I failed.
If not for your family's sake, then for your birthright.
You mean like, curiously through me?
Like a child actor?
As the princess of the underworld.
That's me!
But I thought my brother is gonna inherit the underworld.
What do you mean you failed?
You tried to beat Cronos yourself?
He hurt you?
Concern yourself with your own pain, not mine.
You are the one who is hurting me.
Destroying Cronos shall not change the past, and the pain shall linger.
That will assert itself less frequently with age.
But enough of this.
On the morrow, we shall teach you to hunt greater prey.
Oh, my god!
We're gonna start killing.
Cause teach a child how to kill.
Kill, kill, kill!
Death to Cronos.
Of wait...
I don't have an arm, you're right!
I just noticed that I'm armless.
Let's pet the frog.
Alright guys, I know this is a short, really short stream.
But I'm gonna call it here, because I'm tired.
We're gonna call it here.
We did stream like two and a half hours today.
I'm like super tired right now.
So we're gonna call it here.
I don't want to force myself when I'm like really tired.
But I honestly had a great time playing Hades 2.
I think like I'm gonna play Hades 2.
I'm gonna wait until like the game gets out of early access to keep playing.
Because I don't want to like spoil myself.
I don't want to spoil myself the full game.
I want to experience.
And then like, and then when the game officially comes out.
I get like, I like, I like, you know.
I get bored of it.
So I want to like, the next time I play Hades 2.
I'm gonna wait until it's fully released.
And then we'll play back to where it started.
I don't want to get burned out on it.
Yeah, I don't want to get burned out of it.
And like I actually sort of like want to...
I want to like be able to experience the full story.
In the way that the game wants me to.
So the next time we're playing Hades 2.
We're going to wait until the full game is out.
But I really enjoyed it.
I really enjoyed it so far.
I enjoyed the different power-ups and everything.
And I cannot wait to play Hades 2 when it's out of early access.
I hope, I heard they're like planning of getting it out of early access by the end of the year, right?
Or next year.
We'll see.
But yes, I had a great time.
I'm sorry that it was a really short stream, guys.
But honestly, I'm like really tired in general at the moment.
I think it's also because like there was a lot of stuff going on behind the scenes.
So I'm like mentally, my brain is just so exhausted at the moment.
I might take a nap right now after this, after I end stream.
But I still hope you guys had a really fun watching me play Hades 2.
Being the many, the 877 subscribers.
And the streamer you watched today.
In the past week that played this game.
Anyway, everybody.
As always, everyone.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.